(chanting sounds)
- Hey guys, I'm Letitia Wright.
- I'm Martin Freeman.
I play Everett Ross.
- And I play Shuri.
We're going to do
"Would you Rather."
- "Would You Rather"
- One, two, three...
Nah, I got it.
- Okay, go.
- D'you want me to go first?
- Duh.
- [Freeman] Would you rather
have to wear Black Panther's
suit every time you left your house--
- or Iron Man's?
- Ooooo.
- Seriously?
- Imma say Black Panther suit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah...
- Far cooler.
- For sure.
- I would say Black Panther suit.
- Yeah, I agree with that.
- Yeah, I'd have to go
with Black Panther.
- Everything.
- Panther.
- Yeah, why?
- Because I made it.
- Yeah, of course.
- Why?
It absorbs sound, run on walls.
- Claws.
Claws!
- Come on.
You got claws.
- It gives a new meaning
to "talk to the hand."
- [Freeman] Would you rather
have Nakia's ring blades
for hands or Thor's hammer for legs?
- I kinda like my hands.
- Mhmm...
- I think I could cope
with Thor hammer legs.
- Nakia.
Nakia.
Am I not Wakanda?
- Thor's hammer for legs.
- Really why?
- It's solid, it's rectangular,
and you can just like...
- Yeah.
- What're you gonna do with ring...ring
- Ring blades, yeah, that's a good point.
- I could do this...
All I do--
- Which he does all day.
- All I do is this...
- All day.
- You can't even pick anything up.
- No, that's true, like
Edward Scissorhands.
- It's stupid it...yeah...
- You just kill everything.
- [Gurira] Would you
rather have to fight for
the last slice of pizza against Shuri
or X-Men mutant Storm?
- Storm, 'cause then I
would just get the pizza
and it's raining.
I don't care.
- Imma go with Shuri just because I think
if I'm fighting Storm it
can get a little outta hand.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah...
- Know what I'm saying?
Like lightning and rain...
- Yeah, yeah, yeah...
- The pizza'll get ruined
and it'll be no pizza left.
- (makes wind effect)
Okay, eat up mate...
- Who has pizza, Shuri, what?
- I think I would fight Storm.
- Be a good fight.
- Yeah, it would be a good fight.
- [Jordan] Would you rather
be big-spooned by T'Challa
or W'Kabi after a night
of Netflix and chillin'?
(laughter)
- D'you wanna be big-spooned
by T'Challa or W'Kabi?
- Who made these questions?
- Ayyyyyyyyyy....
- Answer the question, young lady.
- You know, you know...
(laughter)
- I'm gonna go for T'Challa
'cause I just know him a bit better.
- T'Challa, definitely.
- T'Challa...
- Black Panther, sorry bro.
- Kinda relieved, but kinda hurt.
Is this confusing...
- W'Kabi has a blanket.
- That's true.
- Yeah, I dunno, maybe keep you warm.
- Yeah, yeah...
- I'm gonna go W'Kabi.
- I'm easy either way.
- [Gurira] Would you rather
have an indestructible car
made of vibranium or an
indestructible cell phone
made out of...
- Indestructible car...
- Car!
- Car.
- Who cares about a cell phone?
- I know, who cares?
- I don't even like calls now.
- I'm going with a car.
- I'm going with the cell phone.
- I'm gonna go with the car.
- I'll go for the cell phone.
I use my cell phone
more than I have a car.
I don't have a car yet.
So if it falls at any, you
know, it's indestructible.
- I dropped my phone, I
literally just got my phone
and I dropped it the same
day and cracked the screen
and I felt some type of way about it.
The car, I don't plan
on crashing it or any...
People with insurance go up, they drop me,
and then I won't be able
to drive a car anyway.
- [Jordan] Would you rather
find out your Uber driver
is M'Baku or an angry Hulk?
- That's easy, M'Baku.
- Yeah, yeah, M'Baku.
- It'd be an entertaining ride.
- But M'Baku would take
up most of the car space.
- You'd need a lorry.
- But no, but then, angry Hulk as well.
- M'Baku.
- Yeah.
- The Hulk is...that's not pretty.
- I think if it was the Hulk it would be
a really short ride and I would die.
- Angry Hulk, to me, has no
redeeming qualities at all.
- Angry Hulk.
- M'Baku will give you a
lot of falafel sandwiches.
- That's a very...
- And at the end he goes, "Are you done?"
- M'Baku is sort of funny.
- Yes.
M'Baku, yeah.
- [Duke] Would you rather
consume a heart-shaped herb
that gives you superhuman
strength or immortality?
- I kind of am quite
interested in immortality.
- Immortality sounds amazing,
but is it immortality
like death becomes dirt,
like, does your body
rot but you just don't?
- No..
- Or is it like when...
- You stay fabulous as we always were.
- Okay, so like right now.
- You'd be completely fabulous forever.
- Yeah, I think I'm gonna
go with immortality.
- I'm gonna go for superhuman strength
'cause I think immorality
is ultimately unnatural..
- Torture.
- And not the way we're supposed to be.
- Superhuman strength.
I don't wanna be around for too long.
- Yeah, I think superhuman strength.
- I dunno, time for that, what
kind of immortality is it?
Is it that I'm gonna be
healthier or is it like
my body's gonna shut down
but I'll just be alive.
- Just alive like here...
- Yeah, no.
- No.
- Kill me.
- And all your friends would be gone.
- I'll make new friends, no, just kidding.
- That's true.
- [Wright] Would you
rather find out you're on
the Dora Milaje's wanted
list or the Avengers?
- [Duke] Ooh, ooh, bro!
- The Avengers.
- Oooooh, Dora Milaje's fierce.
I think I'll have more time
to live with the Avengers.
- Actually, you know what,
no I'd rather the Dora came after me
'cause I like looking at them.
- I knew you was gonna get saucy with it.
- I like looking at them.
- Okay.
- Uh, Avengers every day of the week.
I knew that black women is stress.
I warned you, I...
- Black Woman will find you.
- They will find you
and they will bring you down.
- I've got it.
I'd rather be on the Avenger's.
- You are wise.
- I'm wise.
(funky, groovy music)
- Yeah, that's it.
Would you rather has killed it.